(electronic music)
- [Narrator] Previously, on Bro-Dependent.
- Heh!
- Fuck!
- I spent last night in your sister
and I fucking cried when I came, dude.
- I've watched her fuck
up, like, 100 guys.
- Do I smell weed?
- [Group] Fuck you!
- Can't you see we're, like, fighting?
- Zac, are we fighting?
Owww!
- Yeah, I guess we are, fuck you!
- Fuck you, dude.
- No dude, I mean it.
Like in a mean way.
Fuck you.
So I was like, "We are so happy."
and Anderson was like, "I
hate that you two are happy."
and then he tried to punch me
but I blocked his fist with my hand.
I just like, crushed it
in my hand and threw it
off and got him down on the ground.
- Huh.
- Isn't that crazy?
Like I didn't think, like, I
would have that much strength,
or, like, agility for that
matter, but, like, I did.
- And Zac was just like,
"Our friendship, means
nothing to me."
and I was like, "Dude don't say that."
and he was like, "Bam, Butterfly Knife."
and I was like, "Oh, fuck."
and he came at me and I was like, "kafwa!"
and I disarmed him, cause
I didn't want to hurt him.
That's pretty fucked.
- Right, and what does that have to do
with you working here at Lids?
- Uhhh, You're asking me
about my experience and
that was, like, my most recent experience.
- Nah, I was talking about
your retail experience.
- Ohhh.
(laughs)
dude, my bad, whoa.
Yeah, no, I have no retail experience.
Nor any job experience of any kind.
- Hey, I know you man.
We auditioned together last week.
(laughs)
I'm Jacob.
- Cool.
- You goin in for Conner?
- Aw, no, no I'm actually going in for the
part of go fuck yourself.
- Wait, what?
- What role?
- What roh?
- What role.
- What roh.
- I'm saying what role?
- What roh?
- What?
- Stop.
- What'd you say?
- Okay, thank you very much.
Okay, Mark you're up.
And, we can hear you in the next room.
- Oh, really, can you?
- You mind just keeping it down?
- Bitch.
(laughs)
fuckin told that guy.
- Yeah, that's good.
- Oh, Babe, I was thinking
like, since I'm over
at your place all the time,
anyway, maybe I could,
like, bring some stuff over?
- Awwwww, or you could
just put an overnight
bag in your car.
- Oh yeah, yeah, that's a great idea too.
- Yeah.
- Well I'm sorry man.
I can't give you a job.
- What?
- I know, I know, it's a real bummer.
I've never, not hired somebody here.
- I would very much like to work here.
- Yeah, and you were halfway there.
You had a hat on, you didn't have sleeves
on your shirt.
Those are two pluses here.
- This is fucking bullshit, dude.
- And what is this?
- My resume.
- It's five words and a dick.
(laughs)
- Yeah I drew that.
- Okay, I just need
you to slate your name.
- Hi, I'm Zac Michaels.
I have to be here.
- Okay, um, do you have any questions?
- Uh, yeah, so my character Conner,
he's just like, some dick in a soap opera?
- Umm-Hmm, you're actually
gonna to be reading with Wesley.
- Remember me?
- Conner, I never thought
I'd see you again.
- Well Valentin, I never
thought I'd see anything again.
But I got my eyesight
back and I can see things
clearer than ever.
Your face, your beautiful
reconstructed face.
It's like water to my parched soul.
- I can't quench your
soul-thirst Connor go.
- If I can't have you,
I'll shoot my eyes out.
Using the same gun that
took Tyrone's life.
The end, can I go now?
- That was quite good, Zac.
Are you available next week?
- Oh fuck, did I get it?
(techno music)
If you wanna see more check
out Comedy Central dot com,
also our YouTube page, also
subscribe, also comment.
But if you're gonna
leave me a comment, like,
try to be creative, you
know, like, I've seen
"You're gay", "You're gay",
"This is gay" so, like,
maybe try to call me something creative,
like fuck shovel or something.
Thanks so much.